Greetings, good evening.
I hope you've, I trust you've had a fruitful day.
I do not say happy, although I wish it had been happy for you.
Namotasa Bhagavato Harahato Sambha Sambhodasa Namotasa Bhagavato Harahato Sambha Sambhodasa
This evening I just want to start with a practical question that's come through.
It's from Danny.
I have a technical job assembling electromechanical units.
This involves reading a drawing, collating the parts and getting the parts to fit together.
I try to maintain a degree of mindfulness, but with all the movements associated with these activities, it becomes exhausting.
Instead, I note walking from A to B and standing, but I spend more time at the bench.
I have tried to note looking and seeing during these times, and even with this, I'm aware of other actions too, and then note that I'm ignoring these objects to force my attention on the seeing.
This can be followed by frustration, again noted.
My formal practice is one of slow noting, even though, for example, when I raise my heel, I'm aware of the other touch sensations, but do not note them as independent sensations.
My question then is, how to maintain mindfulness at work when I'm involved in an activity that needs to be done with relative speed?
Now, this is, by the way, a regular sort of question that comes from people who practice the Mahasi technique.
The Mahasi technique is a very specific technique for a particular type of situation, the retreat technique.
And the whole idea, of course, is to slow everything down.
And the noting is a way of stopping the mind from wandering.
It has this other purpose, which is to turn everything into an object.
You're pointing at something all the time.
But in terms of this question, the retreat or the Mahasi technique is about slowing everything down and noting, especially intentions,
and becoming more and more refined in order to see how the mind is creating the world that we're experiencing.
Now, when you go out into daily life, I was, uh, I didn't, I didn't have trouble, uh, this sort of trouble because I had started with Zen and, uh, I practiced about throttle whole, um, in Northumberland and, um, uh, yeah, Northumberland.
Yeah.
Uh, turn left at Newcastle and, um,
There we did things at speed, I mean, really fast, and for long times, an hour, two hours even sometimes.
And I remember one time, for instance, I was given the job of the dining room, and part of it was polishing the chairs.
And I had to polish the chairs as if they'd never been polished.
And you did it at great speed.
And the understanding is, of course, is that the faster you go, the more you've got to keep your mindfulness.
Your attention is right there.
If your attention wanders, then you'll drop something, you'll trip up, you'll make a mistake.
It's not as though mindfulness stops you making mistakes as such because accidents happen.
So I never had this problem of transferring noting into daily life because frankly, I never did it.
It was
It didn't see, uh, because of my Zen training, I knew that what I had to do was just, you know, put my attention on what I was doing now, uh, when you are doing something, especially something that, uh, you know, demands attention.
I mean, careful attention, such as the work that, um, um, uh, Danny does, uh, then of course, uh, noting can get in the way, uh, because your whole attention is towards the object.
Now, those of you who've been here know that when I talk about meditation at work, doing the chores in the morning, then yes, the idea is to be with what you're doing.
And sometimes there's a sort of confusion about self-awareness, that you have to be aware of yourself all the time doing something.
But that's, of course, a split consciousness in the sense that
One minute you're aware of yourself, and one minute you're aware of what you're doing.
So that's not where we want to end up.
Self-awareness arises quite naturally, and you can't get rid of it by creating another self.
It just creates confusion.
But as you keep paying attention to what you're doing, then there's moments of absorption.
Now, this happens to us quite easily when we're watching something exciting like a film.
You absorb into the film.
you know, you disappear for a couple of hours.
And then when you come out, you say, Oh, that's a good film.
And it's the same with hobbies.
Uh, when we're really interested in what we're doing, gardening or something, time can just fly by.
And that's, and that's when we lose that sense of self, somebody doing something.
And with it, of course, a sense of time, it always happened to the computer a lot, you know, and other, other, other ways like Facebook and all that.
So,
When we're at work, our effort, of course, is to be attentive to what we're doing.
Now, it might be that some noting helps us just to pay attention to that.
But in a sense, we don't want it to get in the way.
We want to pay attention to such a point that I'm just being my doing.
That's the trick of it, you see.
So it's not a case of being self-aware of what you're doing.
It's not a case of being aware of everything else around what you're doing.
It's a care of, it's a case of one pointed concentration work that you're supposed to be attending to.
So it's not a case of, um, noting everything specifically.
Uh, and at times you can just drop that when you know that your attention is steady, when you can trust it to remain with what you're doing, then you've arrived.
That's it now.
When you go into an absorption where you lose that sense of self and you're just doing, of course, how you enter into it is the state of the mental state that you'll be developing.
So if you go into it with a calmness, a sense of just doing, a sense of equanimity or whatever, or even a sense of kindness, I mean, that's more easy if you're tending to people rather than a machine and stuff.
Or with a machine, it would be more carefulness, to be caring.
It makes everything easy if you can bring your heart into it, give it a good reason for doing what you're doing.
And if you go into it with care and attention, affectionate awareness, excuse me, then you come out with more of that because you're developing it.
If you go in there with a sense of rush, then of course you're reinforcing that attitude and you come out with more rush and that can lead to an early exhaustion.
So I'm presuming that what Danny's saying here is that trying to note and do the work, he's found exhausting and rightly so.
So the thing to do is to do the work.
If the mind's very jittery, it's going all over the place, then yes,
Keep noting a little bit just to put your attention there.
But as soon as you feel that you're holding your attention and that you're involved, then let go of it, right?
Just be aware.
It's enough.
So now if that didn't answer the question, especially, Dan, if it didn't answer the question, just send me another email.
And, yeah, do feel free to send questions about your meditation practice and so on.
Very good.
so i'm finally arriving at the um the question are all the stages of the eightfold path equally important um now the short answer is yes but some precede the others so they have preference in in sense of preceding the others but eventually they're all uh important in our practice and so uh
first thing is to be clear as to what these um the right the the eightfold path is actually referring to here so remember we've got right view right understanding which is followed by right attitude right intention and then you have right speech you have right action right livelihood it's interesting and then you have right concentration right awareness and right right effort right
awareness, right concentration.
Now, interestingly enough, when you actually talk about this as a practice, you start off with Seeler, you start off with morality, which is right speech, right action, right livelihood.
And then you talk about the meditation.
And then finally, you talk about the wisdom, the right view and right attitude.
But when you're actually talking about it as a
logical process as to how it actually you know knits all together then you talk about it in this eightfold way so i'm going to follow just the eightfold path not the not the teaching way of sila samadhi panya which is morality concentration or attentiveness and wisdom yeah so uh when the buddha talks about samadhi right view right awareness
um he's basically referring to the four noble truths as the basic as the base of our understanding and from a practical point of view from our practice point of view in terms of vipassana it really is relating to those three characteristics of existence that um the cause of suffering is desire that everything changes uh
Nothing actually changes into something else.
Everything is quite spare, quite distinct.
And there's this constant impermanence going on.
And that everything is not self.
From a human point of view, everything is not self.
Everything isn't substantial.
Nothing can exist on its own.
It's always in relationship, in dependency on something.
so obviously the body's dependent on the air that we breathe and so on um and the heart dependent on relationships and the mind dependent on information so everything has something to feed it's got to be fed it's got to be related to um but the interesting thing is at this summer summer ditty this summer right view is really about conceptual thinking and if you think about it um
Everything that we experience during the day, everything we look at, we hear, etc., etc., it's always fitting it into a particular concept.
This process actually has a word in psychology, apperception.
So you see something and you've not seen it before, and when you look at it closely and get close, oh, yeah, well, that must be a type of fly, yeah?
where you taste something which you haven't tasted before is oh well this must be a type of chinese dish so you're always fitting it in to your preconceived concepts your preconceived ideas which have been built up ever since we were born and a lot of them are sort of subconscious we're not fully aware of these concepts that we are always looking at the world through um
Uh, the obvious ones, um, things like freedom.
Now, you know, what, what do we mean by freedom to you?
And this idea there was, I remember a few years ago now there was this whole thing about the right to insult, which is a very sort of, um, aggressive way of saying that, you know, you can say things which might upset others, but the, but the, the way it came across was that you had to go and punch somebody.
with your new ideas or with your view.
So this whole idea of free speech, the whole idea of personal liberty, the whole idea of democracy, parliamentary democracy, all these are great big concepts which manifest our relationship to the world we find ourselves in.
And there's the negative ones, there's all the prejudices, sexism, racism, ageism.
Now, I'm very much aware of ageism these days.
So you can see the way we look at the world is always coming from some preconceived ideas.
what the buddha says is that uh unless we can really correct these ideas let's go to correct this uh these perceptions these conceptions then uh we're just not going to get out of the of the mess we're in and that's why he's uh always keen to uh to deconstruct what we experience and to begin to investigate what we experience so uh the main one is of course
The one that we, shall we say, directly experience virtually all the time is this relationship we have to pleasure and pain, pleasant and unpleasant.
And what he's saying is, if you remember from the beginning of the discourse last night, it's neither indulging nor is it being averse to something.
So we're trying to lift ourselves out of this reactivity, which comes from a fundamental
misunderstanding somewhere as to where we can find happiness.
Yeah, that's where the base of it is.
We all want to be happy and we're all chasing happiness.
We've all got our own definition of happiness and it's all coming from this wrong understanding as to where we can find true happiness, yeah, or true well-being or true ease with living, an accommodation with life which no longer is painful for us.
So Samaditti is that.
And included in that would be the very important teaching about karma, the fact that when we act, there are consequences.
That's a real experience, a real understanding.
I mean, there were teachers at the time of the Buddha who said that there was no...
There was one, especially, Velati Puta, I think his name was,
who said it didn't matter if you went down one side of the Ganges, full of compassionate act and generosity, and at the other side, full of murder and thieving, it wouldn't make a difference at all.
It had no consequence.
So there was all these peculiar ideas going around at the time, and the Buddha was clear about action and consequence of action, and that the action had to have some awareness of what you were doing.
So killing something by accident or, uh, you know, the usual thing of say sometimes here, I've not done it so much here, but at Gaia house, I remember when I was there, I'd be walking in the dark and I could hear this crunch and it'd be a snail.
I just stood on, you know, um, and that, I wish I didn't mean to do it.
You know, I've got, I've got a natural regard for snails, um,
And that wouldn't be considered to have bad karma, except that, of course, one feels guilty anyway, one feels bad anyway, but that's not necessary because there wasn't the intention there.
So the whole teaching about karma, it comes into this right understanding.
Now, when we've got this right understanding, as I say, that comes first, and it begins with understanding
what we hear what we're told um what we receive and then as it were it becomes our own personal uh knowledge our own personal understanding when we think about it often uh i'm sure you've found that you've understood something but when you've tried to explain it to somebody else you can't do it and so that's the same with this with this growth of understanding the first is is to
through your reading through your listening etc information comes in and then somehow you've got to sort of think about it you've got to activate it within yourself and then it becomes your own uh property and then of course it has to be reinforced by direct experience and that's that's vipassana vipassana knowing knowing by way of direct experience
And that's when it becomes your own personal experience.
And then you find it has this flowing through the rest of the path.
And the next thing, of course, is that it changes your attitude.
It changes what you intend.
Some people translate it as thought, which I can understand, but I don't think it's quite right.
I don't quite get across the meaning of samasamantam.
Samasankapa, excuse me.
Because when that's described, it's described as moving away from greed and selfishness towards generosity.
And it's a process of renunciation, renouncing that wrong desire.
So moving from greed towards generosity.
It's described as moving towards hatred and aversion towards love and acceptance.
And it's described as moving away from harmfulness
from cruelty, from one-upmanship and all that sort of stuff towards compassion.
So these are attitudes.
And it's out of these attitudes that these intentions begin to manifest in a given circumstance.
And from then, of course, you're into right thinking in your mind, which is a sort of speech.
I mean, you're talking to yourself.
Then it goes into right speech, right action, right livelihood.
And all this is supported by
by your meditation okay and we'll say a bit more about the about the right speech right action and all that and especially right livelihood actually tomorrow evening so that's the
That's the short answer is that all these sections in the FO path are equally important, but that some precede another, right?
And of course, right understanding precedes them all.
It then has the effect upon your attitudes and then the rest flows naturally depending on the circumstance.
So sometimes you're talking, sometimes you're doing something, sometimes you're at work.
Okay.
So if any questions arise about that, you know, do send me an email.
So I shall leave it there for this evening so that we can get back